okay everybody with more and more
details coming out about Avengers
infinity war one of the extended scenes
released this week showed us Cherie
Black Panthers sister working with Bruce
Banner to save vision Sheree uses one of
her camellia beads to scan visions body
and project a hologram of the mine stone
and yeah banner and Sheree exchange some
tech gobbledygook about visions
structure being polymorphic and banner
having to attach each neuron non
sequentially and sure he just out
hitting banner by saying he could have
just reprogrammed the synapses to work
collectively we all got that joke yeah
actually to quickly explain what they're
talking about here banner is referencing
the scene in age of Ultron when he and
stark brought vision to life they had
just recovered the Android that Ultron
had started to build using the mind
stone stark proposed instead of
destroying this Android to use Jarvis as
the androids inner OS which eventually
led to to vision coming life and now
banner is saying it the way they did
that is by going nerve cell by nerve
cell in the living tissue and attaching
them to Jarvis's programming polymorphic
refers to a language in computer science
which in which one interface in this
case Jarvis connects with different
variables in this case of various nerve
cells and of his vibranium enhanced body
Sheree suggestin a suggestion is to
reprogram the nerve synapses to work
collectively similar actually to how her
vibranium tech works in which T'Challa
can simply think I would like my suit on
please and then the vibranium
organically weaves around his body
and unlike vision he doesn't need the
magic of an infinity stone to do this
okay that's probably made it more
confusing but essentially I thought you
were just gonna give us a breakdown of
age of Ultron I was like a little bit
bummed and then that was really because
I had to kind of like re-examine to be
like oh that's exactly how they that's
it that's interesting that they bring
about that detail here I just got from
that she's sassy and smart that's a good
comeback great that's essentially what
she's saying here she conceived is
something that the two smartest
scientists in the world Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner overlooked and I like a
vision is learning that he might not be
the most perfect version of himself that
he previously thought he was he's kind
of got that look like hey come on fix
that though
I mean his body's built like he could
his blink and then just like real
changes no its collectively there was an
easter egg someone's like no vision
actually doesn't wear put
clothes on he makes his body make the
clothes and I was like you just made
that way more conv sweater but guys be
on this tech babble it's interesting to
think what is the context of the scene
well in the background you can see cap
into chawla and Scarlet Witch it seems
that they have brought vision here after
the Black Order tried to steal the mine
stone from visions head and now they're
analyzing visions anatomy perhaps hoping
for a way to safely remove the mine
stone without killing him now a few
questions for you guys one do you think
this is even possible to do that and to
who do you see as a smartest character
now in the Avengers universe I think
they're gonna make a decision where it's
like removing this down we will kill him
and they're like oh yeah maybe had to
die yeah maybe I mean I don't know like
if she's able to reprogram the whole
body he has access to technology that is
just leaps and bounds ahead what were
used to like we've already seen like
with some Martin Freeman's character
buh-buh-buh fine we can war machine
definitely goes to Wakanda with them too
and so just like he's just a little
salty probably walking can't it's a
machine that helps them walk it's like
and you want to help me help help a
friend out I'd be really help I usually
in the comics it's like this other comic
book II reason he doesn't have the soul
stone up there it's a different
character that has some soul stones at a
more red or the mine stone him get music
I'm warlock has the soul stone this is
the mine stone yeah getting them
confused usually it's a sort like a
solar beam and so he the way he doesn't
he doesn't need to eat he just absorbs
like solar II doesn't need to do these
all plan hey maybe let's keep it on a
maybe yeah I think uh it seems like this
might be part of missions arc in this
movie right like do I need these soul
stone is or do I need the mine stone is
that the whole source of my my power and
my identity or can I detach it for
myself and I am my own person
there's gonna be a moment with scarlet
witch as well she'll be like I did not
want to lose you know
[Music]
they'll be moment I also I love the
scene in Civil War when he's like I
don't know what this is like I don't
know if it's me or if it or I can use it
they do have a really beautiful moment
Bertha though he's actually it was great
really appreciated that they talked
about fear and what it means to be both
of them they're like we don't really
know what we are and so but it's okay
because I'm not really
yeah then sweater sweater just got
stopped making sweaters the smartest
character in the Avengers universe
guys it's Cherie yeah it sounds like a
16 year old Cherie is just like wiping
mouth yeah she's young right now like
just imagine how even more brilliant so
good again she's had access to
technology that hasn't really existed
anywhere else apart from Wakanda so
that's you know a bit of a head start
but she's schooling these guys it's
beautiful it's beautiful and some people
were like well she'll be the new Iron
Man I was like sometimes she's black
panther or she could just be a scientist
who makes the whole world she can just
be Sheree and she could just be herself
and have her own character we'll need to
have reassigned someone else's mantle
mmm that's a good gift yeah Robin is
dying guys yeah well anyway guys let us
know what you think about this scene do
you think visions whole identity is
based off of his infinity stone or gem
as some of you only comic readers are
quick to point out or do you think that
guys are fun other intelligent people
who were missing out on does it can't
they just all be friends and scientists
don't have to bicker about everything or
compare their intelligence let us know
what you think guys hmm remember to
subscribe to new rock stars and follow
us on Twitter at new rock stars and
weigh in and keep an eye out for other
infinity war videos that we're gonna be
doing thanks guys